bigger question i have now that we're
you know we're we're in the gist of it
let's talk about these riots
have you heard about what they're
calling the red mirage no did i mention
that to you earlier so
what they're saying is that donald trump
the democratic uh analytics firm said
trump will landslide on november 3rd
democrat said that
and then over the next week biden will
win because of mail-in voting oh i saw
your tweet
yeah it's a tweet right well i did a
whole video about it okay i saw
something on that
and so here's here's wow right so
this is a this is a guarantee for
disaster because
if on election night they say donald
trump has won
every state you know but california
oregon and washington
people are going to be like you did it
trump supporters going to say he did
it and then a week later they're going
to come back oh by the way biden
actually won they're going back no he
didn't
i saw it i watched they said trump won
they showed he had all the states
there's no way this is not real the
biden supporters going to be like you're
not counting the votes properly biden
one
and with both sides are adamant that
they've won what happens
okay i'm gonna give this is where i give
my live stream addendums
so that we don't get you busted here
i never sponsor violence i don't promote
violence uh whatever yada yada whatever
else i have to say to not get fired or
get this live stream taken off
but uh you know bringing into this
we are in a clear factionary state we
are there are two
sides in a powder keg waiting for
somebody to set off and i want to remind
people
how the civil war started and how civil
wars do start
civil wars and we were talking about
this earlier
aren't usually what people think where
it's like oh
everybody's blowing each other's brains
they're marching red versus blue
watching
why do you think there's like oh this
battle or there's a battle of gettysburg
like why do we have these like famous
who or battle of iwo jima like
why is there famous battles it's because
war is strategy there's specific places
and regions
where you do your fighting is not to
exhaust limited resources
especially because it's hard to get
public and proper public
backing to a civil war it's definitely
something that i would say the majority
of populists are usually opposed to
in most times and no one wants war on
their dwarf doorstep especially a
developed country of people
who have seen it happen in other
countries that we are fighting for
democracy in
um but i will say this
this we are and i i will declare this
here
i put my branding slightly offensive
backing i cannot put the blaze backing
on this but i put my branding
i think we are in a soft core civil war
and i mean you know the other type of
hardcore soft core
i think i think we're in an overt civil
war but what i'm saying about soft core
meaning like
like to me it's like because you know
i'm not gonna
listen to my wording here in the 80s the
70s 80s and 90s someone would find a
magazine
you know a kid would find it of their
parents or whatever and be like whoa
what's going on there
then with the advent of the internet we
got all these
weird categories of this kind of adult
like content yeah
and and and so now people who once
perhaps uh were excited i'm let me go
with my words lydia's looking at me i'm
being good
or perhaps i'm being careful about this
we're perhaps
excited by something very simple
something etc
that's called softcore are now deadened
inside to the most
atrocious and weird types of things the
mind could think of
in that regard and i think that's what
we're seeing with this violence and this
stuff and kind of what i call myself a
soft core
civil war producer because we're kind of
like producing stuff that people are
getting desensitized
to this so it's like oh another person
yeah stabbed and shot
so this is okay let's see something
harder it's escalation
and desensitization so we're softcore i
mean it's software because people are
like
it's it's people are are dead into the
to the isolated incidences it's like
okay another person shot whatever no i
think portland
ends your software theory that's
hardcore there i mean they they targeted
them
yes but the media has done a pretty good
job at still lying to them
it doesn't matter whether whether
they're people who believe one thing or
another what matters is
a guy with with uh who's under
investigation he writes his nickname
no no i'm talking about the far leftist
guy who is accused of this
right now under the assumption that we
know who the guy is the murderer
because they're investigating the guy he
has a big black lives matter tattoo on
his neck
he yelled we got him right here we got a
couple right here someone else just pull
it out right here yeah
then jane the other guy turn around the
guy who dies pulls out what
it appears to be that he pulls out mace
and then takes two to the chest
the wit the friend of of jay uh uh i
think his name was
aaron danielson said that they were
watching i think aaron johnson is the
victim his friend is chandler papas
they called uh his name is aaron j
danielson they called him jay oh you
know
i'm saying his friend was is chandler
papa yeah yeah well i don't know the
guy's name yeah yeah but his friend said
that they turned around when they heard
someone yell
we got him right here we got a couple
right here pull it out
they turned around and they says before
he knows what happened two shots were
fired
and then his friend staggered down and
died at that point
it's i mean we're it's almost i mean
maybe it's not but maybe it is the shot
heard around the world that that we've
crossed into hot territory
we've been seeing low tier skirmishes
and we've been seeing resource battles
for the past couple of years
i was talking about civil war a few
years ago
and a lot of people scoffed and laughed
about it and then the things i predicted
started to happen
and then i talked about earlier this
year that they'll show up to your house
and then they show up to cassandra
fairbanks
i did remember earlier on you were
saying that i didn't think you were
lying
i was just there in the midst of this
and i remember hearing reports from
people like you saying
they're coming to the houses and i
remember thinking in that moment like
that's going to be so weird when that
happens and i didn't know it was going
to happen
like it's happening faster and faster
and faster i didn't think so
following the death of the guy in
portland antifa started making posts
saying they need bulletproof vests and
ballistic gear
yeah they're getting financing outside
financing they really are no that's
expensive i'm gonna tell you this
i have i have a company which i'm not
going to plug on your show because i
wanted to plug my own sponsors but i
have a great armor company to sponsor my
show and i see they're providing me all
this stuff
ballistic helmet everything um conceal
stuff yeah and and i looked at the price
tag that they're
saving me from from paying and it's good
quality stuff so this is not
useless american-made stuff to buy
50 40 you know vests and helmets i mean
you're like 600 bucks but
tens of thousands of dollars for all
this stuff nobody that's there
has tens of thousands of dollars to give
away who's funding this
they raised two million dollars for for
jacob blake
they're they're launching gofundme
fundraisers and gofundme allows it
they're posting on twitter their venmo
and their you know cash app or whatever
and they're getting money from random
people online
probably a lot of people outside the
country too the point is not so much
about financing because i think uh
and we'll definitely talk about donald
trump's uh theory about you hear what
he's talking about the planes full of
thugs
he's right it's true very interesting
it's true it's just the media doesn't
want to take the the honest assessment
and interpret what he's actually talking
about
but so i'll just talk about this donald
trump said that there are planes full of
you know thugs and uniforms and that
somebody saw this on a plane they got
very scared
what the left imagines is a bunch of
like big dudes wearing military gear
getting on a plane to go rough up the
rnc
what the person probably saw was a bunch
of leftists with patches
and like blm tattoos getting on a plane
and that happens
all the time i don't know if you see
this because you fly around
all right i look i'll tell you this so
i try to be careful because even when i
film footage that
is not debatable good old articles and
periodicals like the intercept very
dishonest places
will do whatever they can to discredit
you so i try to keep
this stuff out of the air but um one
thing now there's these
do you know about these really
incredible like journalists that have
risen out of
these riots like kailyn delmeda from
scriber drew from lives matter i think
yeah
yeah yeah there's yeah you guys have
them tomorrow there's drew george
ventura shelby telcott
richie mcginnis from the daily caller
these are just
andy no of course everyone knows andy no
these are just incredible people who are
out there just exposing this stuff
and one thing that a lot of them have
mentioned is like when you fly out of
major qa airports like los
angeles and you will have people on the
plane like when i was going up to
sacramento or when i'm going up to
portland people are on your flight
with helmets and stuff and they're not
press right
nobody brings helmets black clad helmets
and stuff i'm watching people and this
is where the the kenosha stuff
the police found out right that there
was 44 different cities in the
detainments and arrests 175 arrests 104
i believe were from outside kenosha i
see
the same people and and i know drew will
will echo this i see the same people at
cities
across the country and at least but see
here's the point i'm openly admitting
i'm not from those cities i'm not there
to participate
in the demonstrations i'm not being
dishonest i'm being honest my intent is
to go there and to capture the events
to put it up on twitter so people can
make their own judgment create my own
show so if people want my opinion
they go watch slightly offensive
whatever do your thing but if you are
getting on planes
i mean you look at these people they're
professionals i think in in portland uh
it was portland one of the people was a
google engineer yeah that got arrested
we we uh we used to call these people
the tourists uh because we knew that
we knew who they were so i used to do so
so so trump brings this up and the media
and all these leftists are calling i'm a
conspiracy theorist right now and i'm
like
when trump said that i was like and
because i used to fly
at at the peak of my career covering the
stuff on the ground i flew
about 1.7 times per week if you did the
actual math so just about twice per week
i was flying on some plane somewhere
were you like executive platinum or
something oh definitely yeah of course
there's free upgrades the first time
absolutely
oh yeah that's the life yep i'd walk
right in like out of my way
but uh but i'd notice you notice two
things the journalists always bring in
their tripods
and the far leftists go into the riot
and i always thought it was funny like
when i'm flying to you know st
louis i went to st louis back and forth
several times oh you'd see him in new
york
there would be like four or five people
wearing clothes with patches and cymbals
and marks all over their bags with like
slogans or whatever you're like i know
exactly what that person's going to do
i always tell people though it's not
cheap i'm sorry i'm sorry it's not
expensive it is cheap
flying is not that exciting what about
driving though because okay you know
they're driving did you know what the
antifa snack fan
yes it's the antiqua snack van savannah
hernandez from action seven
she was in portland um about a few days
earlier of the rnc
speech with trump and she had recorded
uh
the snack fans tires being slashed
people don't know what this is i
remember that
um this is big white van there's a big
white van that offers supplies
to auntie of a varied supplies there's
this weird thing at these riots where
people like love passing out
snacks like i i don't know about you but
like i don't know i mean like
cheez-its are good but like cheez-its
paired with molotov cocktails
there's better combinations there's
better combinations don't don't
underestimate
giving people food i mean so snacks you
know childish like no
smack right you know the history of
gatorade
enlighten me so they used to it was the
florida gators i could be getting this
wrong but i'll give you i'll give you
the gist of the idea
they used to shoot pickle juice when
they were playing sports because it's
got electrolytes it's you know salty
brine
i love it they decided to make an actual
drink that would help keep them hydrated
and keep their electrolyte levels up
people
underestimate how much better you
perform
when you're properly fed and hydrated
so when when you see the antifa going
out and giving out energy drinks or
giving like
they're literally fueling the unrest
i don't know if you're going to charge
someone for handing out bags of
cheez-its
but when people are running around and
you give them food energy
you are ensuring it goes on longer
particularly if you're giving out drinks
energy drinks sports drinks or whatever
i didn't i didn't you know and i think
that's where the complicitness in in a
lot of these riots come from
different factors and i want to bring
this up like whether it's short distance
by the way the point of the intimate
snack man is it was in dc a few days
later which is crazy
crazy yeah yeah in in but i'm saying
like so
you'll notice the same outfits like a
certain flag that was in chicago that's
in kenosha
that's more understandable okay somebody
drove from chicago kenosha i did the
same thing
let's not get too you know out there
with these ideas
everyone's you know going across borders
but what i did know is i i do
ask people um austin fletcher i
mentioned him earlier a really good
creator
early in 2017 2016 used to ask people at
the end of them complaining about trump
famously oh who did you vote for and
they would be like i didn't vote right
the new thing is you know oh jacob blake
like i have multiple interviews which
there's so much unreleased footage on my
channel and things i've been releasing
recently because
once you involve some sort of a gun
related altercation et cetera
the the everything else that you could
post is not worth it at that point like
i understand the journalists it's just
not worth posting you don't know
it's like an archive well yeah i know
but at that point right i didn't upload
a bunch i interviewed people and i'd ask
them
they'd be like you know jacob got shot
this is kenosha this is our county
and i'd be like where are you from oh i
drove in
uh i drove in from missouri and you're
like
well look i'm all for
people that you know wanting justice not
that the situation is
as is a case of justice or injustice i'm
not going to comment on that i i
according to the accounts of people
involved it looks like it was probably
warranted
but i'm not the jury or the judge here
but i will say this i'm going
don't this is a this is a monday night
and i'm thinking
this is my job so i'm here because this
is my job
where did where do you work and
like you know from traveling on trips
the cost you add up the hotels and food
et cetera
where are you staying though like where
are these people
that's easy it's not expensive to do
what they're doing
but you say that as a guy who's
established a lot of people 10 bucks is
a lot of money when i first got started
i had no
income and i would just be like hey if
you want to support my work you can go
to my we pay
and then i would get it so it's
crowdfunded anarchy but it's not just
that
i i'd post i'd post a tweet anybody got
a place i could stay at in los angeles
and i'd get 50 responses
yeah people do message me i'll offer me
by the way thank you people offered me
like someone to offer me the other day
for a brisket but also even cooler they
actually come for brisket i wasn't in
town
i i uh drank a beer on set with uh
stubber gear who's a host at blaze and
it turns out that
the owner of the of the brewery
um you're not gonna know which one cause
you don't know what episode that was
is actually likes the right coverage in
the show and now i'm gonna go get some
beers
at the place but i get what you're
saying is like the the connections
people are passionate about this stuff
and they want to support it
so you're saying you don't think it's
because people say it's like oh the open
society it's it's soros you think it's
more just no
crowdfunded it's it's not even
crowdfunded it's social credit social
currency
so uh i still know a lot of this a lot
of people who do this
yeah you tweet anybody at a place i can
stay boom they have facebook groups they
have
they're well organized a lot of people
are like how are they paying for this
and it's listen man they say the same
thing about me who's funding tim poole
find out who his backer is and i'm like
no one that's like i run a business with
you know multiple
multiple revenue streams i fund myself i
work for no one i have no deals with
anybody else
i sometimes mention that you can buy
emergency food
you work harder than most people though
really you put out too much content in a
good way
well so these people can literally
because what i did
when i went to south by southwest the
first time in 20 2012 march
i just tweeted anybody at a place i can
stay and i had 50 offers and i crashed
in a guest house
it was like an airbnb essentially
someone's like here's the keys here you
go
thank you keep it up man good luck i'm
like thank you yeah well you know what
and that's that's why there's this um
it's really interesting right now too
because i know that during the 2016 uh
era
a lot of people rose to influence where
like this is what i noticed is that the
people came out of like 2016 there was
this influencer political influencers
where it was like you don't exactly know
why they're famous but they have
influence and
a lot of them have i mean i'm a married
man i'm not saying appropriately they'll
you know these are a lotties are very
good-looking girls with very nice bodies
that
young men probably just like to follow
because men like to hear
women that look good spouse their ideas
on campus
and news hires a bunch of people right
so so it's like you know and there's
nothing wrong with being hot and using
your good looks to get ahead in life hey
do what you got to do
you know but a lot of these people are
just i don't know what they do and i
don't have an understanding
but a lot of and you know they're good
looking that's my point but the people
who are rising up during this election
season
are like myself like these just like
fugly guys who
who are like hey i'll go i'll go put
myself to go get killed
uh so you don't have to well i've been
around for years but i'm just saying
like there's a lot of these things like
it's just i'm saying the people who are
rising right now show you how serious it
actually is
because you got you raised up then
because you were hot and you could bring
attention and you were a little bit
crass
now it's like you're getting big because
you're showing people
people getting shot like bg on the scene
you seen that journalist or whatever
the guy went from like obscurity to like
twitter famous
in a matter of like 45 days do the work
because he's doing the work he's in the
trenches
generals are made in the trenches yeah
man thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you